chose promise chose due voilà c'est le
premier premier testé pour vous de cette
saison 2012 2013
je suis peut-être un peu fou et je
m'aventure sur le terrain ni taekwondo
eric lander le président du lou du thé
cadets se sont dit m'a prêté un très
beau kimono que j'enfile pour la
première fois dans l'avenir les arts
martiaux sais pas c'est pas mon credo
mort a essayé il m'a donné une belle
ceinture blanche de juniors ça devrait
ça devrait le faire
on va essayer de se frotter aux
taekwondoïste non dans quelques minutes
sur ce faire trop mal pour moi voir ce
que ça donne
testé pour vous
je suis un petit peu en retard j'espère
que ça mais je suis motivé à porter sur
taïwan à courir nous avons adopté
ok d'accord je mettrai jamais concentré
jusqu'au bout on va y aller
d'un monde oculaire l'accord 2
tu mets le poids de corps les gens mon
chargeur maria d'accord à la
tranquillité ici un bocal dtc tu viens
je suis le patron inverse
d'accord d'accord à gauche on bat
férocement d'accord
juste que je souhaite
saha
à
on attend juste minutes fougeray
c'est la jambe droite chorfi jambe
gauche là je suis perdu pour la première
fois du coup on est soi
on va pas casser
je le temple
sa part remporté la jambe est en
position tout à l'heure
à
ces deux blocs et aux moyens donc une
question de distance de réactivité et de
timing d'accord si tu par contre tu
prends tu pars trop tôt tu leur as
d'accord c'était pas la bonne distance
du confrère c'est sûr
ça commence à devenir dur de tout
centraliser entre le fait de faire un
cadeau
servez geste normaux et après de se
mettre sur son combat ça qui est le plus
difficile la concrétisation de
l'exercice théorique
je pense que je vais essayer je les fais
à l'échauffement sanary
voilà comment que le bois
c'est le gros fake exercice de
l'échauffement rayonnant pourrait tirer
toutes les versions
bien chaud pendant l'entraînement bon je
suis pas encore un proche je suis pas
encore assez à bord
d'ici quelques entraînements si je suis
assidûment
bon eric merci pour cet entraînement
cette découverte du taekwondo de revenus
on a des grands plaisirs et merci à
gabriel mon partenaire du soir et que
j'ai un petit peu martyrisé parce que
j'ai pas tout payer toutes les
techniques sont en un mois il est comme
ça il ya pour apprendre et alors j'ai
une question dieu et ma ceinture noire
ce soir au bar non je crois qu'il va
vraiment leur retirer le dossier un peu
plus souvent parce que
il ya pas de matière à pau c'est bon
c'est l'egypte bon je vais persévérer
alors exactement
en tout cas merci vont égaler 78 et
merci à toi pour ce super testé pour
vous vive le prochain testé pour vous
wilfrid vous venez avec moi